and scheduling especially the bridge
between the two views of scheduling
coming from the worst case analysis and
the traditional queuing theory I will
have two speakers so the first half will
be delivered by nickel bouncer from
technical university a pint over so this
will be a joint talk between Adam and
myself and I should say up front that
this will not be may be similar or like
a traditional tutorials we have been
seeing before because it's not really
that there are too many connections yet
and maybe one of the hope of the
semester is that there will be at the
end so we will basically just be giving
a few connections and some glimpses of
things that we know might be related so
let's begin so what is online scheduling
I mean we have all seen it in some form
or the other so typically the setting is
you have say one server or a collection
of servers and you have some tasks that
are coming maybe over time and need to
be done and in so this is the scheduling
heading and you're interested in sort of
optimizing some objective and again
there is a whole collection of objective
debating time or fairness through port
and so on you might have various
constraints you know jobs can be
preempted or not migrated or not and so
on it might be deadlines and you could
have sort of various settings you know
single machine multiple machine networks
we could have this whole matrix of all
kinds of possibilities and scheduling
and again there are various communities
look at these things because they're
sort of important and resource
allocation and so on so we'll be
focusing on sort of two extremes in some
sense and again I'll define these later
on so when is the competitive analysis
which most of us have seen where the
focus is sort of you want to design an
algorithm and compare it to what's the
best possible you could have done in
hindsight right so you typically compare
yourself to the best possible thing and
queuing it's the opposite contrast you
don't want a relative guarantee usually
wants some absolute guarantee so you fix
okay here is a particular algorithm here
is maybe a input workload and what's the
exact or approximate expression I can
get so that's sort of one difference the
second difference is again here the
focuses on worst case inputs like really
those determine everything in queuing
it's it's very important to make a model
is what's the precise stochastic model
and then you prove certain guarantees
and again comparative analysis since
your focuses on worst case you typically
come up with sort of a robust algorithm
that for any input will do well or not
and in curing typically your analysis or
the algorithm is optimized to a certain
workload so maybe this is a nice picture
so suppose you have this input space of
all possible instances so in competitive
analysis all the focus is here right so
these are some bad instances and you
know the whole algorithm design
everything is so these determine
everything and in queuing typically you
would partition your space into or not a
partition but say look at the part where
things are nicely behaved maybe
different distributions and maybe try to
give a more nuanced to you for each of
these how well you can do and so on
right so again these kind of same poles
apart and one of the goals of this
tutorial is you know can we still use
insights from one area into the other
and in particular design good algorithms
that may be combined benefits of both of
these ways of looking at things okay so
that's sort of the plan ok so again so
I'll begin with the maybe defining the
basic terminology especially in the
queueing because probably not many
people are familiar with sort of
queueing models and the basic way to
view things and techniques so I will
spend maybe quite some time here trying
to build intuition and then we look at
one particular case study of minimizing
flow time so flow time is again i define
this formally but it's a metric very
well studied in scheduling and queuing
people who probably know this as
response time or so join time and it has
various names and again we will see sort
of how ideas from one field can help the
other and towards the end of the talk I
will highlight some other possible
directions where I feel there could be
some more future work and then Adam will
talk of many more connections in the
second part okay so quickly what is
competitive analysis again we all know
this so in the scheduling setting we
should think of it as you know jobs
arrive over time and the algorithm has
no arrival no knowledge of future
arrivals it and it should make its
decisions based on current knowledge so
more concretely say you have some jobs 1
through n coming over time maybe a job
has a size and arrival time and
and we look at the most simplest setting
when there is just one machine you know
and you want to sort of find a schedule
that minimizes some objective right put
anything in this XYZ so again the online
setting at time T you only know things
that have arrived by time T right who's
release time is before time T and you
create a schedule on the fly and you
cannot do undo past decisions so
interestingly already here you could
define sort of two variants in this
thing you can have a stricter setting
off so what it means to be online and
this setting is called non clairvoyant
or blind setting and we look at this
quite a bit later on so here so this is
stricter settings when a job arrives you
don't know its size right like how long
it will take to finish so all you know
is ok there is this job in the system
you maybe keep working on it and at one
day 10 ounces ok I've completed my
service requirement and then it leaves
right so this could be a stronger notion
of online right so can we still design
good algorithms here so by the way there
are any questions just feel free to ask
and again we said compare the sort of
look at all possible inputs and look at
this ratio of how good your algorithm
does versus the offline best rate or how
well you could do a 9 site and typically
in competitive analysis the solos you
know if you have any problem the Holy
Grail sort of is to you know fight d
right competitive ratio there is sort of
one right answer and typically you try
to chip away from both sides maybe you
try to sort of successfully improve
lower bounds that how well any algorithm
can do and typically this involves
constructing clever strategies Edward
sales strategies for instances and on
the other side you sort of try to design
better and better algorithms and maybe
smarter analysis it's ok we all know
this so let's look at the queueing
models which probably as yeah not many
people know so the most basic the first
thing you study in any queuing course is
what's called the mm one model so M
means for Markovian and so the first
time is for the arrivals and I will see
what this means the second M is for the
job size distribution and this one is
for a single machine setting right so
the picture here is that ok
some server and sort of jobs are coming
at some rate lambda now what does this
mean so this M here means that jobs have
a Poisson distribution with rate lambda
and going to remind you if you haven't
seen this in a while so of course on
distribution you should think of as you
know if I look at any infinity symbol
interval of time say between T and T
plus DT like the chance of this job
showing up is lambda times DT it's
literally the rate and if you use two
more discreet settings you can think of
is the geometric distribution like every
time there is a coin toss and when
lambda probability this job shows up ok
so again it's well known everybody has
seen this is that if you have person
arrivals it really means that between
any two arrivals the distribution is
geometrically distributed or
exponentially distributed and the mean
is 1 over lambda right so this is same
as like if you're tossing coins with
which our heads with probability P you
expect about 1 over P steps until
between consecutive heads now similarly
for the service thing there is a
distribution so jobs have this size
which is Poisson with rate mu or the
service rate of this ok so typically in
the queuing well it says that so this
server can finish jobs at rate mu which
means if you're working on a current job
it put just end like in this small
interval with mu times DT probability
right so it's again sort of exponential
and again so personal trait means meal
means that the job size is 1 over mu in
expectation so let's see so how often is
a server busy if you have IMM one system
so not hard to see that it will be about
expected size / expected arrival time
right so it's so this quantity the load
will be very fundamental so it's good to
understand so if I look at any sort of
big interval of time T how many jobs do
I expect to arrive about t times the
expectation of a right because you know
II job is arriving roughly units of time
and a job one average takes the expected
size amount of service right so I expect
my server
to be busy sort of this fraction of the
time so this is the total time and this
is how much it's busy so this will be
expected size over the expected arrival
time is just lambda over mu right
because EA was 1 over lambda and this
was one word new good and this quantity
will be always denoted by Rho or the
load of the system right and this will
come up again and again in various ways
so it's good to have this definition
here good so again just to sort of
billable on this point if the arrival
rate was 0 point 6 and the service rate
was one server can finish jobs at a
faster rate your load will be like point
6 and we should always assume that the
load is less than 1 because once the
load is sort of more than one things
sort of build up right things do not get
out fast as fast as they are arriving so
the these things are not so interesting
good so once you have defined this mm1
setting can sort of see what we can do
so typically this leads to some markov
chain so let's look at mm one with the
first come first serve or Pfeiffer
policy so when you are say running such
a policy there is a natural markov chain
associated with it right so the state
here means how many jobs i have in my
system so you have currently in some
state I very sort of lambda chance you
go to i plus 1 or there is mu chance
some job finishes and you go to i minus
1 right so this is a wrench Markovian so
there is it's nice markov chain and once
you have a nice mark of J and you can do
all kinds of things you can compute
what's the steady-state probability of
being in state I which in this case
turns out to be this expression where
Rho is again this load right and once
you have this steady state probability
is you can for example compute the
number of jobs in your systems it's just
the average number of jobs
again turns out to be this and maybe
this is a good expression to also
remember for mm1 queue so notice save
your load was half like we expect about
one job in the system to be there and as
this load sort of increases to one I
mean this number goes up right as you
would expect and in general in queuing
one many studies more complex networks
of these red you could have multiple
servers and jobs feed from one queue to
another queue or so on and these things
are very well understood and you get
more complex markov chains that you can
analyze so ok let's look at more maybe
general and interesting setting and this
is called mg1 so then the first M is for
Markovian arrivals but now you have a G
& G is for general so a job size
distribution can be general now right so
jobs don't need to have a Markovian or
exponential service requirement and so
if you have the general distribution we
will always denote the probability
density function of this job by F this
will be a notation so again you can
define ok what's the average size of a
job it's just the average and you can
define a service rate which is one over
the average size of a job because this
is how often system will get jobs out of
the system but notice now this mu is not
like a uniform rate right like an mm one
because it's a general distribution so
it's not a Markovian slow but you can
still talk of this mu good so one thing
is so often this is a very good model in
practice because you have this general
distribution and you might wonder okay
this M may be a bit restrictive but it's
often a very good model because actually
can formally sure that you know if you
have many users say and sending jobs to
a server and these users are kind of
independent and maybe they have their
own distribution on offer they generate
jobs but if you average this
distribution or sum it up over all these
various users you tend to pass on it so
just like sort of central limit theorem
you tend to a Gaussian positive things
this tends to episode so usually it's a
very good approximation or in practice
so you are people studying these a lot
but there are sort of more general
models where you can look at GG 1qs and
so typically things get hard here to get
exact sort of analysis and people look
at all kinds of approximations and so on
so in this talk will mostly focus on the
mg one setting so any questions about
the models good so again we will further
restrict our self will only look at one
performance measure which is the average
flow time so let me define what this is
so the setting will have as a single
machine and yep what what information
does the server know at any point in
time does it grow the distribution of
the remaining does it use that is the
remaining job size too okay so we'll
come so you can define a policy which is
either blind it doesn't do anything or
again so it depends on your queueing
policy right and actually this will be a
relevant question will see several
examples good exactly so this is just a
model I haven't told you what's the
policy right so the simplest policy
would be a first come first serve but
you could also do time sharing or
round-robin so on so this is just sort
of the input model in some sense okay so
we look at flow time what is float I'm
just a quick reminder so again it's sort
of the most natural metric you will
think so again jobs are arriving over
time so these are the release times and
you have some schedule given by a
scheduling policy so the flow time of a
job is just how much time it spends in
the system so when it completed minus
its release time right so maybe just a
quick picture so you have these three
jobs so this is like the time axis this
length denotes the size of this job so
first this red job k maybe I scheduled
it here then I started putting the green
job maybe I interrupted this by this
blue job and then complete the green so
the flow time of this green job would be
this interval right because it finishes
here and it arrived there and this is
the response time so John time same same
things so yeah very common objective is
to minimize sort of the average flow
time or total flow time of jobs how much
like each job activate on average and so
you can ask exactly as commercial asking
okay what's the right policy to execute
jobs with I want to minimize the
subjective and you can have sort of
various policies last come first serve
short a job for shortest remaining time
first
on and again this is very well
understood so for the particular metric
of total flow time it is very well known
and everybody has seen this that the
optimum algorithm is shortest remaining
processing time so at any time say you
have several jobs to choose from you
just work on the job which shall finish
the earliest it so maybe in this pic
yeah yes yes for now yeah okay we'll get
ya so we will assume that the right the
algorithm knows the job sizes otherwise
SR PT is not well defined right so again
everybody understands this policy just
so here is an animation I guess sir what
is always working on the job that finish
is the earliest and one useful think
thing about when working with flow time
is the following so you can express the
total flow time or the objective you
care for so one way is just the sum of
flow time of all the jobs and this other
useful ways I can sum up over all times
how many jobs are alive in the system
right or how many are unfinished and why
is this so so let's look at the proof so
imagine a job pays like one dollar for
every time step it's alive right so the
total payment a job will make its its
flow time its job statement is just FJ
by definition so this is the total
payment but you can also count the
pavement in a different way at each time
step how much pavement is coming in the
system right so there will be exactly
the number of jobs that are alive so
that these two quantities must be the
same good so somehow if you want to
minimize the total flow time you want to
keep the number of jobs slow and sort of
this is also in 188 a way to CYS rpt
should be optimal and again one can also
give other various proofs so the
classical proof is based on this
interchange argument suppose you have
not working on the shortest job just
sort of switch those two and you'll be
better right so again this is all sort
of classic stuff so quick so good so if
you look you know what is competitive
analysis have to say about sort of the
simple total flow time minimization
setting it seems we know everything now
right so we have just shown as our PT is
one competitor women can't hope for
better deal no thing and you can also
show that you know for various policies
first come first
of time-sharing I mean you can come up
with examples which show it's
essentially as bad as it gets so it's
like almost Omega N or into the 1 minus
epsilon comparative ratio and notice
this is sort of the so n here is the
total number of jobs in the instance and
this is as bad as you can get right
because if you have any algorithm that
you know is working as long as there is
work to do actually have an algorithm
that doesn't do anything even if there
is work then I mean you don't want to do
that hopeless but as long as there is a
non idling algorithm it's always n
competitive rate and why is this because
we just saw that flow time is just the
sum of number of jobs alive at any time
rate so what's the best thing that can
happen opt has one job and we have n
right so so any everybody is at least
and competitive right it seems the story
is almost settled from a competitive
analysis point of view I mean what's
want to say you know we could go home
but you'll see that actually know so I
mean there is you can add richness to
comparative analysis and we will see how
you can cope up with these sort of very
pessimistic analysis and ya know so if
you're always working that contact on
yes yes so I'm just looking at the
single EAJA so we'll just look at yep so
then ya gone to a pre-emptive and single
yeah any other questions
okay so okay so this was sort of what
one says about combative analysis let's
look at things from a queueing point of
view and we all spend some time here
because these results might be new to
many people so let's look at a simple
the process of sharing or round-robin
right so here if you have ten jobs you
work on them equally give them one tenth
of the processor so here one can show
that if I look at say a job of size x
that's arriving into my system it's
average response time right so average
over the whole sort of time horizon
right is x over 1 minus Rho and Rho is
again the slower do should maybe think
of load as the row as point nine right
it's a loaded ninety percent of the time
and okay so this is a result in queueing
that this is what it is right so maybe
some notation for TX I'll always denote
sort of the response time of a job of
size x expectation of TX is the average
response time of job x okay so maybe one
way so the formal proof of this is a bit
painful I mean would need a whole
lecture at least to do this but let's
see one very heuristic argument I mean
this is the wrong argument so if some
undergrad wrote it you would give him a
zero on this but still maybe a good
heuristic argument so suppose there is a
job of size x that enters the system
right now we know like in the long run
the server is busy row fraction of the
time right I mean this is the definition
of load so typically this job will you
know get to work one minus Rho fraction
of the time so it's about x over 1 minus
Rho
okay yes sir all right okay let's right
now okay so maybe this is true hero
stick okay so once you have computer
let's say we know this you know you can
then compute the average response time
over all the jobs which is just the
expectation over all the jobs and that
comes out to be the average job sighs
over 1 minus Rho good so few things to
notice here maybe you know so the point
is this skewing result is telling you
something about this processor sharing
policy it's giving you very fine-grained
information so for example one thing you
can glean from this is that the response
time actually doesn't depend on this
distribution gee it's pretty surprising
it just depends on the load there is no
dependence on this probability
distribution F yes so okay so think of
load as being fixed because I mean there
has to be some dependence on something
but the point is okay we'll see an
example for 50 for instance where you
could depend for on the second moment of
the distribution or some crazy thing
right okay see an example yeah but the
point is yeah this just depends on the
size of the job and just the load
somehow it's very very clean and simple
should be surprising and also we can see
from this that this is what you would
expect that process sharing is very fair
because for every you know if a job is
twice as long he waits twice as much on
average which may not be a policy thing
with other policies so you can already
sort of glean very fine-grained
information from these things okay so
let's look at maybe another policy first
come first serve and DC so let's derive
so we'll try to sort of heuristic Lee
derive the expression for this so let's
say I'm a job of size x I enter the
system what will be my response time or
flow time under 50 so when you arrive
you know its first come first serve so
maybe you see some pending work before
you and then it's your size after that
right once you're done come so it's some
may be expected waiting time that you
see before you and then plus X now it
turns out so one can actually compute
the expected waiting time turns out to
be this expression and s here is the
sighs random variable right so you have
XY is the second moment of the job sighs
okay now good so maybe this is it should
so the response time would be like this
expression plus X and this is sort of
very different from process hearing
because there we just had a x over 1
minus Rho right now why this second
moment comes so we will see this more
formally in the next slide but here is
sort of one intuition so actually so
this is kind of surprising right so it
could be that your average job size is
finite some small amount but maybe the
distribution is so variable that the
second moment is infinite so what this
is saying is that pfeiffer will have
infinite average waiting time rates it's
interesting you and one way to see this
at least intuitively is that so let's
say your distribution of job sighs was
that it's some large size m with
probability 1 over m I otherwise it's
one expected time is about to because
this will have expectation 1 plus almost
one from here and let's say load is half
so things are arriving every four units
of time but in five four notice right so
whenever you have this one big job arai
coming of size M lot of these guys so
think of a job like jobs coming every
four seconds just for concreteness so
all these guys will roughly be stuck for
Omega M time after this right so on
average a job will have Omega M time
even though it's average size is just
too it's samosa could see why the second
moment might come and now so let's make
this a bit more precise actually yeah so
let's maybe see how much queuing
intuition people have so far so imagine
i am at a bus stop and a bus arrives
according to a Poisson process with n
minutes on average so every 10 minutes i
expect a bus to arrive when it's
following this exponential interval
distribution now suppose I don't know
the schedule of the bus and I just land
randomly at the bus stop how much do I
expect to wait on average
not fight okay all right so okay one
answer could be five minutes I mean bus
arrives every 10 minutes on average you
know so I arrived half a maybe ok so
somebody who said 10 why 10 ok right so
it's you could also argue so 10 could
also be a right answer because it's
Poisson process its memory less so I
arrived my arrival should have nothing
to do with when the bus is going to come
it's memoryless ooh maybe it's 10 and
what's the right answer I guess yeah
maybe she put a third bullet barrier so
indeed the 10 is the right answer which
might say and this is actually this is
called inspection paradox or length
biasing it's a sort of very counter in
two different uh no maybe when you first
see it so let's do this because I think
Adam will need this quite a bit in his
spurt so let's do this whole detail so
in general suppose I have some random
variable X right which is some
distribution F and let's say there is
this process going on so you know I have
this time and so something happens for X
1 unit so you are sampling X from this
distribution so maybe the first entry is
x1 you wait for X 1 then the next thing
is x2 x3 so for now suppose so think of
these like as the bus arrival times
ready these are these intervals now
suppose a person lands randomly during
this interval right so think of this as
a very long interval and your landing
randomly so what's your expected time
till the end of this particular sort of
X I that you learned in and it's the
sort of product here so this is called
the excess of you know how long till my
a popular nor how long it will take for
the next bus to come ok wow you're quick
you need so right can you find the
distribution of that ok so yeah so this
is called the residual X you know this
is all exactly what we are doing here
and yeah this is a very fundamental
quantity in queuing and let's do the
proof that you see probably had
right so maybe so here is approved by
picture so think of this process as
again I map you know I'm here when this
X this one comes I sort of go up by x1
and there's this interval finish is
right then the next one starts at x2
then it sort of finishes so on now if I
land up randomly so the way I have drawn
it this way is because if I land up
randomly what I see as remaining is
exactly the height of this thing right
so if I learned in the beginning of this
interval lcx to FL and here so the
average so I'm landing randomly so you
can convince yourself the average will
just be the area of this thing right but
these are sort of 45 degree line so if
this is X to Y this is also X to base so
right so the average will exactly be all
of this so at least you should see why
the second moment should come in and in
general if you play around with this
mode you can actually compute the exact
distribution of this random variable X
see which has some form which is Adam
values good so okay so most people got
this edition correct so except mom one
all right so let's look at something
more complicated the srp T policy which
we know is one competitive rate and may
be good to spend some time but to
understand what queuing says here and we
look at I sup it in more detail sort of
the rest of the talk all right so if you
look at a queuing book you see this sort
of so again this means expected response
time for a job of size x I don't know
it's sort of a the easiest expression to
look at and I've already kind of I could
make it look more ugly by so this row of
X is actually this quantity which is the
load of jobs of size less than equal to
X right so this is sort of the average
size of jobs less than equal to X and
remember load was okay maybe
also right load as lambda x so this
would be the total load but if i was
looking at load made of joy jobs are
size less than x then it would be
exactly that expression weight because
this is the average size of jobs less
the next x lambda ok all right so this
is Rho X so it's some mess so let's try
to make sense of this what's going on
here right I think everybody should be
able to even if you don't know queuing
we should be able to follow how we could
have derived this at least heuristic
alee some definition of your lipstick so
again think of your a job of size x you
arrive in the system so what will happen
so this term will actually correspond to
the waiting time you know maybe there is
some stuff before me of size less the
next that has to finish and then maybe
I'll start executing maybe I get
interrupted by new smaller jobs coming
in so on so this is what I will call the
extra time so this is like how much I
wait to just get started and this is the
extra time until actually finish and
let's kind of see what what's going on
strange idea so if you are a job of size
x and you are doing s rpt right so small
jobs sort of get first so how much will
you wait so you look at ok what are the
jobs of size x before me and from kind
of this fifo analysis or this length
paradox something like this so if you
remember again 54 it was lambda in the
second moment of job either divided by 1
minus Rho right but now I am only
looking at jobs of size less than X so
sort of this would be sort of integrated
with the right thing to look at it so
you would expect so row becomes Rho X
because they only care about jobs of
size less than X and this is sort of
some right truncation so so maybe it's
easy to believe that ok so let's say
this is the workload I see before me in
steady state actually if we expand this
expression out it will exactly be this
numerator but let's not do that now this
is the workload I see before me so I'll
wait for that but notice here I have a
square in the denominator and here I
don't so can anybody see ok so maybe
this is your Co so I come in the system
I see pending work less than X
but yeah the pending work is this and
here I have a square so does anybody see
why i have the square there because the
loading is ruined you have 1 minus room
the loading is rowing 1 minus know ok
good so right so it's good to and see
right so when this job came he expects
to see about this much work ahead of him
but notice while he's waiting still more
work of size less than X is coming in
right at rate actually 1 minus Rho of X
the load kind of of these small jobs
right so this sort of pile in some sense
is decreasing only a trait 1 minus Rho
of X so you get this additional so sort
of this is leaking only slowly because
new stuff is filling in trade graphics
ok so this is the waiting time this
argument can be made rigorous didn't
hand wave too much and now let us look
at the extra time so once a job starts
executing you know its size will start
falling from X all the way down to 0 now
let's go a thought experiment if this
job is of size t you know it has still t
units left at what rate is he getting
out of the system so the new stuff might
interrupt him right stuff which is less
than T so he is currently of size T and
that stuff is roughly coming at rate
roti so he's getting one minus Rho T
share and somehow seems at least
intuitively the right thing so so even
though these things sort of look maybe
formidable I mean so there is some sense
to these ok and this is probably one of
the hardest formulas i know in queuing
so if you understand this like you're in
a good shape so good so this was the
thing for a job of size x and so if i
want the average response time you know
i can take average overall X so that
would give you have first time now
notice so if i take another average you
will get yet another integral outside so
it's you know not easy to make sense of
it right it's not so for example this
inside that s our PT was optimum which
you know in a combinatorial way was very
easy to see by interchange argument
I mean here how do you make sense that
for any distribution F this is better
than any other scheduling policy so
sometimes it is not really easy good
okay capital F is the CD the cumulative
distribution function of s
exactly she would get a number yeah
which is exactly the size you yeah so
yeah cueing would give you this very
refined information for every
distribution but the point is here like
so it's giving you this great thing on
one hand but one hand maybe it's hard to
argue about right so again it's very
different from maybe comparative
analysis we have a different focus and
so let's see but you can still sort of
yeah just you know just trying to make
sense this thing if we plug in like and
make this an mm one SFPD does it make
sense okay no idea so I don't know so
maybe like things will cancel out after
a lot of work yeah maybe not even no no
actually i know i'll talk about this
good answer no it doesn't make sense and
actually I've come to mm one I start
weeping continues right there's also
little slow right yeah yeah those are
these results consistent with that or
does not only have work so little slice
something very very basic just says you
can relate the number of jobs in the
system with how much time it spends
right so you see results to derive some
things yeah so you can use for example
the time a job of size expense to figure
out in steady state how many number of
jobs of size XL have in the system but
that's all little Lord does just lay its
number of jobs two-time returning 12 a
question if you if both is better mm one
a fee for mm one is oddity it's a pity
because the circuit is always optimal is
difficult
yeah maybe not look at on the shaking a
little they're all the same sex I mean
what's wrong flying policies match no
that's a pretty that's a pretty still
better what's temples AMD 10 MV 1 so as
I said md one here md one you write you
another little bit all right queuing
experts can look at it earlier I don't
see but actually this mmm one will come
to this Julie these expressions change
ok so for GG when you can't get an exact
expression and people do all kinds of
approximation and actually I am NOT the
expert on this so maybe should ask Adam
or many queuing experts here so this is
sort of beyond what I even understand in
queuing there is no good expression for
GG one exact expression
any other questions
okay so let's still try to make some
connections because that's what the
tutorial is about okay so let's maybe
ask one question and queuing you know we
are deriving all these expressions you
know how things degrade as a function of
load and maybe the expression and we saw
a few things by four process sharing
least come first serve is also similar
though I didn't prove this right so
notice you know if I just look at as a
function of load what's happening there
seems to be this one over one minus Rho
degradation right as your load
approaches 1 this is and if I keep the
other parameters let's say fixed so now
this is how those system is degrading
now you can ask you know this seems to
pop up all over the place is this
fundamentally inherent and surprisingly
this at least as far as I know wasn't
really systematically studied and so I
noticed about 10 years ago that if you
look at mm 1sr PT and this is uberman
just use your asking actually you get
this funny thing so so again this
expression is what time sharing would do
expected size over 1 minus Rho so just a
very small loss here but you improve by
this log factor e of so log of roughly 1
over 1 1 minus Rho right so at least is
showing maybe 1 over 1 minus rodek
dependence is not completely fundamental
sometimes you can have a different sort
of degradation of behavior and it's
interesting because if you look at any
blind policy or non Claire one policy or
something that does not use sizes like
SR PT in its scheduling decision so like
first come first so all these blind
policies I like timeshare you don't
really need to know the size of a job
you just equally give them processor if
you don't use policy so all of them
would have such a dependence in mm one
and why is this so do people see why
follow from something we have seen
so any blind policy that does not use a
size should have this
so if a policy is not using the size
it's just working on some jobs right
like a trait one and then note so
remember we saw this Markov chain in the
beginning 4mm one like you things move
one step forward with rate lambda and
back with rate mu so all these policies
will have the same Markov chain because
you are just working at rate all the
jobs look the same basically right so
there is no difference I mean it's mmm
vomits memoryless you're not looking at
the size so no matter what you work on
there is rate mu it finishes so so good
so sr PD is telling you you have this
sort of improvement if you have sort of
the knowledge of size we can call this
sort of the price of non clairvoyance
and East mm one setting you know this
improvement ok so this proof again this
mm one is deputy formula is a complete
mess right and even 4mm one this was
quite painful to derive so you might
also give why did I do it so so there
was no apparent reason and I but it was
motivated right so so there was some
connection to comparative analysis that
we will see and that sort of suggested
that there might be precisely this
improvement and so they were sort of
reason to really persist and try to sort
of simplify that thing and we'll see
this connection later it once we see
connection to commit of analysis okay
but still you can ask okay there is a
small log improvement but I mean who
cares right so it's you know you are get
this one- road degradation anyway there
is a small log improvement it's
negligible okay you can say that blind
and SRP are almost the same 4mm one so
okay so good news but here is maybe a
more surprising fact so if you look at
em g one now if you love general
distributions for job says is instead of
exponential somehow things can go we're
sort of it's a very surprising result I
think that if you look at the average
response time so okay so there is a
certain distribution called the Pareto
distribution which is a classic
heavy-tailed distribution where so in
exponential the tail sort of drops
exponentially the probability are bigger
than size x is e to the minus x but
suppose you only top polynomially
this exponent of the polynomial is let
us say between one and two this is
called Pareto alpha so for this
distribution actually can show that s
our PT has an amazing degradation with
load so if your load is approaching one
this performance it will very very
slowly degrade right it's log here
instead of st. i say if you look at
processor sharing instead you had just
one over one minus go so it's
exponentially better than person sharing
so what's going on I mean this is really
a big improvement we can't sort of
ignore but turns out actually here for
this particular distribution there is
another policy a blind policy called
shortest elapsed time first and maybe
I'll first show this cartoon what this
policy so it's exactly what it says so
let's say so at any time it's working on
the job so it doesn't know the size of
jobs it's blind it's working on the job
which has received the least amount of
processing so far it's kind of the
opposite of srp t like you work on the
job that you have worked the least so so
say here's a cartoon so if a job arrives
you know this is the only job you start
working on its maybe you're here then
this new job arrives so now this is the
job where I haven't worked at all so
I'll start working on this job until it
catches up with this now maybe these two
jobs around so I work on them equally
because both are sort of if I work on
this a bit then he is the least time
share but then maybe a new job arrives
and then I start working on him until he
reaches here and so on so it's again
blind and here it turns out how if you
just do a computation it's a bit of a
mess but you can do it so for this
Pareto distribution they almost match up
to constant factors as opposed to
process sharing which is exponentially
worse than srp T so then this leads to a
natural question ok I mean for any
distribution G is there always a blind
policy that's maybe close or roughly
close to s or PT if not how big can the
gap be and so on so here is a result
that we showed a few years ago that for
any gg1 system so ignore the G like it
that no matter what distribution of job
sighs you have there's always the best
blind policy which is within sort of a
log factor of s rpt
close assuming some technical condition
that the second plus epsilon moment of
the jobsite is finite and surprisingly
these results come from competitive
analysis so let me try to give a
connection so what's going on so maybe
in the next couple of slides let's see
what comparative analysis has to say
about such blind policies just quick
question yeah so you su 2 plus epsilon
moments before the death row agent
answer okay good so our area result
won't apply for that setting right so
there we yeah so probably also just an
artifact of our proof analysis cry so we
need so for Pareto I cannot use directly
this is that policy computable you see
yes it is yeah we'll see what the policy
is actually ok oh I see so precisely the
best will not be it's not clear how to
characterize it but we can always find
one policy which is always within log of
this though okay so let's take a bit of
a detour on competitive analysis of
blind policies so again there is you
know you're in the blind setting right
you don't know the job sizes and you are
comparing with sr PT which sort of is
the ultimate thing so it's not a
surprise that any policy must go bad in
fact it by more clever lancers you can
also push this to almost Omega n but ok
so this is bad news and let's see how
these lower bound are constructed right
so even for specific policies I mean if
you look at time sharing there is a bad
example which looks like this we give
two jobs in the beginning of size one
there may be a time when you give
another job of size half and so on so in
this case like SR PT would just you know
maybe delay this job and just finish
these guys as they come and has like two
jobs on average remaining but you can
see that process sharing just like keeps
piling on and on and never finishes
anything right so that's why it's sort
of in competitive similarly shortest
elapsed time first can go wrong in the
competitive analysis sense because we
are looking at the worst case input rate
so you get a job of size one and just
when this was about to complete Edwards
will give another job right just when
this was about to be done he gave
another job and so on so a CTF will not
get rid of any of these jobs
you have almost ends up in the system s
rpt of course could just sort of them
right and just have one or two jobs in
the system right so that's why they are
all omega n competitive so this is not
saying really anything interesting right
so committee of the notion seems to sort
of pessimistic to give any good inside
so yeah so we need to sort of come up
overcome this pessimistic behavior and
so there are several ways of doing this
you know smoothly the analysis and so on
here is one way what's called resourcerg
mentation which is quite common in
scheduling soaked Elena sudra man proves
had this very nice paper where they said
let's do this thing where let's give the
online a slight advantage over the
offline algorithm right and by giving it
a slightly faster server let's say by
like 1 plus epsilon so again online
you're giving extra power but you are
comparing its performance to a server
which has still the speed one processor
right so then it turns out so this is
called resource entation and you can
prove sort of very nice results in this
setting and this kind of also has an
intuitive connection right because if
you can show that ok so let's see
actually what we know so for instance
one result you can show is that a CTF is
1 plus epsilon speed 1 over epsilon
competitive ok so if you give it just
ever so slightly faster processor then
sort of this bad example that we saw
dies away right and in this picture it
would make sense because if I give it a
slightly faster processor you know it it
wouldn't suffer from this right it would
actually finish this job before this guy
came it is a slightly faster processor
and get sort of the analysis is not
toward you can make this intuition
precise and show this but interestingly
turns out for process is sharing you can
construct bad instances where even with
like speed up to your Omega n competitor
right so that really takes a long time
to sort of and somehow maybe this is
giving one distinction between PSNS etf
so we saw like in the queueing world you
get this fine distinction right like
what Pareto distribution setf was had
this logarithmic growth with load PS was
linear growth with lowered one so maybe
this is sort of one way to reconcile
these things so the point is you often
the D subsequent ation can give also
very nice qualitative information about
such things good so yeah so now so let's
try to work towards how we prove this
result about the one that there's always
a good blind policy close to sr PT so
quickly something so if we have a rant
so in competive analysis you can also
look at a randomized algorithm and maybe
i should define this because it's a bit
different from the queuing setting right
so queuing there is randomness on the
input but in the competitive analysis
world again so the input is kind of
worst case but you only have some
external randomness right you toss coins
and do something and then your algorithm
still so you can define a randomized
competive ratio as worst-case over all
inputs but sort of now the expected cost
of your algorithm / or / up based off
line so then standard competitive ratio
and here it turns out that if you love
randomized policies there is a very good
blind policy right so we saw that if
it's a deterministic policy like time
sharing or whatever they are all bad at
least Omega cube root of M but if you
love randomization can design a very
good algorithm which is log n
competitive and this algorithm is
actually sort of just a discrete variant
of this short st lap times for so let me
maybe quickly describe this so so
imagine so shortest elapsed times worse
always works on this job that's like the
most new right has the least amount okay
so you can think of it as let's say
there are many sort of cues this is with
threshold 248 and so on so first all
jobs enter here once like every job here
has received two units either it
completes or let's say it goes here so
so if you are always working on the
lowest Q if it's not empty it's kind of
like a CTF discrete virion ok so again
if you just have these discrete
thresholds it will be bad it's a
deterministic algorithm but their idea
was that if you for any job Jay let's
say for class I if you choose a random
threshold so in so to do di you add some
exponentially truncated noise like about
2 to the I over log n sort of mean
then actually you kill that bad example
right because now for adversary there is
no way to so so again the bad instances
sort of this job is almost done but it
doesn't quite finish right but now if
you sort of randomized these thresholds
you don't have this problem because if a
job is not finished most likely it also
has a lot of work remaining on it and so
now you can relate as rpt to this so
using this sort of very nice analysis
they showed for there is a log and
combative randomized algorithm and then
this was extended to sort of the
multiple machine case by Betty and you
naughty and yeah you get a login instead
of this deterministic thing so let's see
how we use this ok actually before I do
that so a couple of things so this login
is also the best possible so one can
give a lower bound on the randomized
combative ratio of any algorithm so rlm
or MLF is really optimal and sir I want
to say this gap that we saw between mm
1s rpt and let's say mm one processor
sharing it was here we had this log
improvement so this was kind of
motivated by this result because so
let's do the following thought
experiment right okay so there is a
tight log and lower bound for sort of
any randomized algorithm and how does
that lower bound go so it's something
like this so suppose you have n jobs at
time 0 which arrived and they have
exponential job sighs with mean one
right now let's look at time n minus
some small like n to the point nine nine
right so what would I expect so you
would expect about n to the point nine
nine jobs a job is of size one right you
would expect this many jobs to remain
and in blind exactly these many jobs say
plus up to plus minus root and would
remain because it's kind of memory less
right so it has these you know there is
still this much time to go and tell you
are in n and write each job could finish
within one time step because the
memoryless property so you'll have this
but opted if it's doing srp t it will
only sort of retain the large jobs right
on the last n to the power
99 jobs are kind of a size log n because
it's exponential distribution it soft
will have much less jobs you get sort of
this log and improvement between these
things so this kind of suggests that
maybe if you have mm 1s rpt like in
steady state you know it might retain
only these bigger jobs so this log n
would somehow should translate to this
because n is the number of jobs in the
queuing system which was like 1 over 1
minus Rho so this was sort of one way
for growing reason for going through the
calculation an idiot worked right so how
do we show this more generally so can
this is this theorem remind you that any
there is always a by spine policy within
this of opt okay so the idea is to sort
of relate this first case an average
case using Seau's minimax lemma actually
we just need the weaker direction so
let's go over this so so what is the
queuing system you can think of it as
giving you a distribution over sort of
lot of instances right so if you know I
have some say mg 1 or gg1 queuing system
so what is it some jobs are arriving so
if I plot the workload pending workload
so this graph is independent of the
queuing policy right because if you are
always working this is a fixed workload
and then the server is empty everything
is finished then there is maybe a new
what's called a busy period and so on so
you can think of a queuing thing as
giving you sort of these instances with
some distribution given by the GG one or
whatever okay now Yao's lemma says that
ok now if you have a distribution on
input instances there is always a good
deterministic algorithm whose which is
not too bad compared to operate its
competitive ratio as within the best
randomized ok so again maybe those of
you have seen this it's obvious but
maybe let me note so you can sort of
bound this right and this we know for
our MLF is log n right so this would
suggest that if i look at the best blind
policy so if these let's say things for
of size n these base periods you should
be within login of our ml of srp d
good okay so this suggests that if these
things were of size on but what is N for
a GD one system so we need to understand
what is the number of jobs here but we
kind of understand that you can show
that ok number of jobs in a busy period
is roughly this so this would suggest
that okay so best blind policy should be
within log of this thing get so instead
of n I just plug this ok so this almost
works but there is a slight problem you
need to do more work and maybe this next
awhile to see so the point is right so
on average a busy period has like n jobs
in it which is this but you know it
could be that all sort of there is this
positive correlation going on right so
big busy periods affect you much more
disproportionately she imagined like
they have a lot of fake busy periods of
size zero I mean that would have no
effect but that we bring down the mean
number of the option of busy period so
you get a much sort of higher pain from
sort of bigger busy periods because
they're more jobs they are delayed more
so on so you need to sort of understand
this correlation so sort of we do the
natural thing so you know we pick some
threshold n naught which is let's say
much bigger than the mean jobs mean
number of jobs in a busy period which is
like 1 over x 90 so think of sears like
1 over epsilon so for busy periods with
like less than an odd jobs life is good
rate we are within log and not factor
just log of 1 minus 1 over Rho and now
we just want to say that these big busy
periods do not affect you too much so
natural ways to bound that contribution
is just that you look at all these busy
periods the worst contribution then they
can make is like the length of this busy
period times the number of jobs that
were there in the busy period because
maybe job is delayed by that length ok
but these things are maybe complicated
random variables correlated in weird
ways so but to understand that we can
sort of use d couple them via holders
inequality and then it sort of boils
down to just estimating these moments
times and won the some analysis and
things fall out right so in its a point
is just morally yeah like this is the
right number of jobs yo to be a bit
careful about sort of Islam things so in
some sense here be related worst case to
average case we are as many machs
theorem and yes
some interesting insights so again one
immediate open question in this area is
how do you extend this to multiple
machines right and the problem is
somehow now these busy periods and all
are not uniquely defined it depends on
how you scheduled jobs and so on even
though our MLF is still poly log
competitive so morally you should expect
things don't change but it's not at
least immediately clear how to push this
framework and maybe just one minute on
c'est possible other quick connections
so so there are sort of have been few
attempts to connect queuing and maybe
more adversarial insights so there was
one very nice paper again almost 20
years ago by Kleinberg at all where they
define a notion of adversarial queueing
theory right so they try to sort of take
this notion of load from queueing theory
but sort of extended and I Edward serial
sin so in any window on average you have
load row but things could be a serial
this sort of proved nice results so
that's one way and maybe this hasn't
been explored as much as it could
there's also smoothies analysis which
sort of in the similar flavor stochastic
and worst case and there have been a few
results on this one thing I could be the
thing could be very interesting is now
trying to design new algorithms which
kind of combine the best of online and
offline right so and maybe Adam will
talk a bit about this so for example a
self-tuning algorithm you know if your
input was really worse case okay you're
no worse than the competitive ratio but
if your input had some pattern or some
nice distribution then you should
automatically converge to the best
queuing thing and so on it's so and
presumably using say learning techniques
one could do this one but also sort of
you know it hasn't been much working
online algorithms on networks or servers
which have been studying and queuing a
lot so it's one direction and maybe
another thing is so in online people use
potential functions a lot for analysis
which I didn't talk about but it's a
very common technique and in queuing
people call these things Lyapunov
functions which really are the same
thing and maybe as often yeah sort of
there are very clever constructions of
these things and maybe there could be
sort of more synergy trying to use idea
from one to the other and with that let
me stop thank you
a couple of questions just a comment
alone so I mean we get it because you
know we do this holders thing yeah so we
could be for technical so sr PT at the
mmm one right there was this log gap so
it's tight in some sense right because
blind in mm one always has this one
minus Rho but we saw in sr PTU is that
the question yeah because there is
actually this law I mean there is one
distribution in particular the
exponential where you have this log
so what are the type of results that
exist for worst-case scenario so the
idea is instead of working the
expectation try to illustrate the yield
behavior so Adam we'll talk much more
about the tales on Sonya wait for part 2